chaque lots est là mais casser quelques
ou collants hélas la quête dolega
crédible aujourd'hui on va pas le
japonais ensemble pourquoi parce que
j'ai tourné un jeu qui s'appelle leur
apprend le japonais pour survivre et la
ghana battle j'ai des petites bases en
japonais un par exemple tous les taux ne
connaissent qu'un organe qui dsk
rayot comme marwa el gato gaza aymane al
et gâteaux gaza et m'achetait voilà on a
fait le tour de mon japonais c'était
extrêmement rapide nouvelle partie oliva
ce jeu et design est pour t'apprendre
les bases du japonais tu apprendras à
lire et à écrire les caractères de
l'alphabet et la ghana tout au long de
ton aventure
allez c'est parti c'est un beau jour le
ciel est bleu la neige et blanche tout
autour de moi c'est tout simplement
magnifique
un ami me rejoint bonjour monsieur je
peux vous aider desbois quelque chose
est ce que tu me comprends quand je dis
[Musique]
qu'ecolo non si calais bagot non ah non
désolé j'ai pas tout compris
ok on va le suivre mon ex qui se passe
non mais attends il a manqué là j'ai
même pas brut japonais qu'est ce tu veux
non mais aussi tu ne peux pas contrôler
le japonais tu n'avais pas contré mais
sort [ __ ] ok il a appelé des
caractères japonais attaquent sur le
caractère elle ça marche pas et monique
je veux fait [ __ ] par japonais vas-y
battu moi un sushi d'accord mais qui
fait trop mal à ok ça marche je n'arrive
pas à y croire il est trop fort il a dit
que pour le battre il faudrait que
j'apprenne le japonais allez on la
prendra plusieurs semaines sont passées
depuis le début des terribles évènements
du village clair notre héroïne a passé
de nombreuses heures à aider à
reconstruire le village le mystérieux ma
japonais oublier beaucoup de ces
guerriers ra ghana dans les terres aux
alentours du village
pire of fame of rock est déjà prendre un
crayon et un post it sur internet bien
sûr j'ai toujours avec un vieux un
cahier à côté de man alors le langage à
poney à un unique système d'écriture
constitué de trois différents types de
caractères il ya les caractères hiragana
et katakana et le kanji auquel il agace
c'est l'alphabet basique et en
l'apprenant tu peut presque dire tout ce
qu'il est possible de dire en japonais
il ya 46 lettre qui constitue une [ __ ]
ça va être long nous on en a b c d e f g
24 27 chaque caractère est utilisée pour
représenter un son unique ou une syllabe
et je note tout mon gars ça fait des
années que je n'ai pas écrit au
critérium sur un cahier à petits
carreaux
révise tes notes tous les jours et tu
connaîtras bientôt tous les caractères
qui constituent les lagana splendide
[ __ ] livre ce jeu tant gérard napias
on va aller individuellement sur chaque
caractère et je vais t'apprendre à
l'écrire à le prononcer à la fin de ce
chapitre on aura un petit quizz donc
fait tomber au [ __ ] les symptômes
égard acteurs sont connus comme des
voyelles à y ait eu eux au n au t1
prenez-vous aussi regagné 1 si l'on fait
pas les make up [ __ ] en fait va
falloir essayer de trouver des repères
ces mémos technique la cea en fait c'est
un thé auquel tu ajoutes le oh oui je
connais cette lettre la regarder si on
retire le thé ça je le connais ce jeudi
au chargé raison alors le gars guerre
suivant c.é
ah ouais c'est ça c'est le [ __ ] ça je
le savais en plus bosser parenthèse quoi
les parenthèses c'est le il voit l'art
permet aux techniques on est bien ok
c'est bon je lai on est bien on est pour
le mans je retiens tunisien et ces deux
derniers qui vont faire que je vais tout
oublié comme une grosse merde alors qu'a
été à suivre ça c'est le hockey au coach
est nu en fait le eux c'est comme le u
mais tu ajoutes une vague on est en bas
voilà c'est mon repère le mot technique
ça vous aide n'hésitez pas à mettre un
bouchon
ouais c'est ça c'est vraiment comme le u
mais avec une vague honnête en plus est
le dernier à agen vecteurs sont le haut
j'ai dit que de la merde alors si on
retire le thé ça je le connais ça se dit
oh [ __ ] donc ça c'est un mix entre le
1er et à grosse mer mec j'ai tout noté
j'ai tout noté actuellement sur ma
feuille
normalement je suis bien donc le à ckoi
c'est le thé avec un mot le hisser les
parenthèses le pus jeu j'ai tout oublié
ok ce parti je suis avec mon geng aux
mondiaux on a envoyé des guerriers je
vais [ __ ] tout ya pu y a à a- à a eu
lieu au nickel du coup on vient se faire
kidnapper dans des caractères de
l'alphabet très bien donc là tu fais
fight et je te dis que le caractère c1 à
aller à l'aimer et la bd c'est bon je
les trouvais c'est nul allez voilà je te
jure que tu termines ce jeu je suis
perdu tu connais vla la femme et
japonais moyen bien joué mais eric et
léo ils ont été capturés par les deux
autres guerriers hiragana jean peuplé de
mes voyages la neige ça veut dire je
veux pas y aller si je contraire ça
nagerait cassé mon aux [ __ ] le hd
bien intégré là y'a pas de soucis le à
illéla à l'hérésie la dégage à une peau
ok l'ucao alejos le faire okello est
mort j aime mon combat contrat et hoarau
sont décédés allait suivant va retrouver
nos poteaux on n est jamais pris
nommément j'avais une chance sur deux
bons voilà je suis je suis un connard
[ __ ] encore un à taxer que des as à
chaque fois céder à je te jure âgées
roger tout choc taisei ajouté armand
l'équivalent d'un chauny pour google ils
sont là regardez qu'est ce qui s'est
passé tv qui n'a plus grosse merde allez
on aurait dit si ça veut dire je sais ce
qu'on va apprendre d'autres caractères
et à la fin on va devoir auteurs disent
très certainement et au total honoré 46
il ya des gars hiragana plus fort en
dehors de la forêt oh merde on leur
apprend un peu plus de choses avant de
braver les dangers
alors nouvelle leçon 5 nos caractères à
la synchro et dur laza rez-de-chaussée
kaki que coco ho
je pense que j'aurais dû continuer de
farm et les monstres dans la foi dans
laquelle j'étais pendant encore 15
minutes pour vraiment connaître par
coeur les caractères mais bon allez
vas-y tu as tu remarqué à quel point
c'est similaire par rapport à ce qu'on a
appris juste avant tu prononces
exactement la même manière tu rajoute
juste 1 4 devant c'est vrai c'est parti
pour le premier caractère cas auquel cas
un [ __ ] halage là là je vais faire du
caca c'est sûr mdr hockey en continu qui
c'est un des gardes et se regarde bien
dans le si l'on voit un d eux d ça
correspond aux petits donc robert hue ou
techniques toc toc toc qui est là
daniel parce qu'on voit un des donc
c'est daniel cayla et quand on voit le
déconseille gagner lé là eh ben on a
envie de poser la question qui est là
qui sait quoi c'est le veut comme pire
technique du monde qu alors lui causé
une seule parenthèse sécu quand ces deux
parenthèses ses y voilà ok suivant
qu'est donc ça c'est une parenthèse avec
un thé en vrai ça va aller ça va je
pense qu'on a manqué des relations
compliquées
non ça va je pense que je suis prêt à
affronter les plus grands monstres de la
forêt et l'achat et marseille ok c'est
parti mais qu'on va mettre tout ça en
pratique j'espère qu'on va être cassé
dès que fit avec le stress là on va se
faire un gros falloir autres le
caractère c'est de la merde [ __ ] je le
savais alors qu'est ce caractère c'est
un cetain que que ça il va prendre
tellement cher ce combat que là où il
fait mal j'ai pas ta wii c'est bon je me
suis gouré [ __ ] ok on a eu c'est bon
tu as si je m'étais gorée le problème
que j'ai actuellement quand j'apprends
c'est que j'apprends dans un certain
ordre je me repère parce que j'ai mis
les six là dedans incertaine ordre et
c'est en retournant la syllabe d'avant
que je devine qu'elle était assise lab
d'après fin bref bref je me suis
comprise et l'important un nom on dirait
que le point mort ok faut que j'aille de
l'autre côté là bas chercher des bouts
de bois
c'est parti pour ce faire un gros des
mille fois ok celui du bas est un e je
le sais c'est parti mais non c'est par
sakho mais le co voilà ça me passe bien
mieux et lui c'est un battant sans
regarder je veux pas tricher 5 je crois
que c'est un cap je touchais pas sûr que
c'est un cas yes je serai le roi du
japonais je vois un cas et je vois qu
les rondins de bois sont à moi au plus
tard d'octobre qui est là c'est daniel
pipes qui tu vas faire le sma produiront
dans un bois avatar et 2,1 et 2,2 et 2,3
randin deux mois et on n'a plus qu'à
refaire tout tour assure un groupe hardi
1000 caractères et vend des bons donc
c'est inquiets c'est un à un et c'est un
coup à voir le qui est bein ça fait mal
au cou ça et voilà le pot est réparé on
peut passer rejoindre l'autre côté où il
ya quelque chose de très fort pas loin
oh [ __ ] c'est quoi ça oh [ __ ] mais
c'est un groupe argovien caractère
menacé lui c'est normal c'est ok c'est
parti nine joe rokocoko ragots
cicciobello là bas ça vous c'était boom
et il a fui comme un lâche bien jouer la
team et ben voilà les amis cela 27 vidéo
et/ou fout pas et pousse bleus c'est
hyper mal à d'avoir faire rpg qui
t'apprend le japonais en plus tu vas te
donner à ce que tu as envie de gagner de
progresser c'est notre instinct trainer
c'est plus fort que nous citons codage
seul ça me sens bien au japon bon choix
parce que ça veut dire mais au moins je
souris prononcé c'est déjà bien sûr les
cartes des restaurants aux autres
procédés commerciaux regarder si vous là
pour les japonais je vous conseille
vraiment jeu il est pas très cher et
franchement c'est hyper efficace après
deux manches et ils ont tenté ou bien
celle du monde
[Musique]
ça